voici survie beauté
bonsoir alors surpris beauté vous êtes
l'avocate de michel blanc donc on a
donné des nouvelles du michael ton très
souvent ici
les sommes récoltées pour permettre à
ses parents de payer des avocats de
payer les voyages de sa mère à bali où
il est emprisonné à vie je répète il est
toujours en prison
comme tout le monde pinal amendes
pénales des entendu ça s'est réglé d'une
certaine façon grâce à votre générosité
et maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe
nous avons rencontré thierry de
multiples problèmes sur l'acheminement
du recours en grâce jusqu'à d'ailleurs
la perte d'une partie du dossier par
l'un des magistrats a chargé du suivi de
la faire enfin le dossier ce recours en
grâce est arrivé dans les bureaux de la
présidence et nous attendons maintenant
l'avis du ministre de la justice alors
est-ce un signe positif je le prends
comme cela mais je reste très prudente
le ministre est allé voir la semaine
dernière michael à la prison c'est la
première fois qu'il fait une telle
démarche c'est très rare il s'est
entretenu avec lui plus de quatre heures
et la maman hélène était là aussi est
venue alors tant sur le dossier que sur
la contre enquête que nous avons
diligenté m quito et moi même que sur la
jaille à la personnalité de michael qui
il est et d'où il venait et ses
highlights et donc beaucoup intéressé à
lui
il est reparti alors c'est un peu le
chaud et le froid parce que le lendemain
la maman était convoqué à l'immigration
lui expliquer que ses papiers étaient
périmés et des ailes donc on est on est
très inquiet bien sûr on espère toujours
ce qui pouvait se passer ce serait un
avis de la présidence peut-être 17 août
2002 le jour de la célébration de la
fête nationale
voilà je dois dire que les autorités
françaises continuent à nous épauler à
se mobiliser d'une manière très efficace
vrai ça oui c'est vrai je peux pas en
dire plus parce que tout le monde tout
le monde de jouer
oui le président le quai d'orsay et
surtout l'ambassadeur sur place qui est
d'une efficacité du mobilisation
formidable
voilà alors maintenant c'est vrai que
nous travaillons d'autres choses se
passent je peux pas vous dire tout vous
l'imaginez bien et puis et puis on
croise les doigts et on espère pour le
17 août et puis si le 17 août la
décision rendue ne répond pas à nos
attentes et bien peut-être nous
prendrons d'autres mesures nous verrons
donc on attend vraiment la grâce de la
présidence indonésienne en est réduit là
aujourd'hui absolument absolument est
évident que si cette mesure n'intervenez
pas on se reverra peut-être en septembre
et à ce moment là on continuera nos on
continuera à se battre et on ne
désespère pas parce que il faut que je
arrive moi la famille tous nous tous
nous tous à sortir michael ealy à 4
jours sa maman m'a téléphoné il y a eu
une sorte d' émeutes à la prison il est
sorti indemne de sa y parait qu avec des
couteaux et des canifs des cutters des
dizaines de détenus entre eux se sont
massacrés paraît que ça a été
épouvantable
il ya eu deux morts à la maison d'arrêt
de demba sarr et et on est très inquiet
parce qu'on est inquiet pour ça pour sa
survie et d'un côté les autorités lui
ont donné aussi quelques quelques signes
et d'humanité puisqu'il a pu se faire
soigner il était fatigué il était malade
il a reçu des soins à l'extérieur de la
prison
donc c'est vrai que on espère beaucoup
mais on est très inquiet
deux ans et demi oui parce que la seule
chose qu'on demande nous c'est pas
qu'ils soient exemptés peine c'est qu'il
fasse en france une peine pour ce qu'il
a fait de mal quoi c'est tous ces
messieurs déjà 2000 repris 4 ans
normalement moins que ce mois et que ça
en tout cas à marseille il aurait pris
18 mois je pense que de paris il aurait
pris il aurait près peu près ça 2,1
ainsi il a maintenant largement subi la
peine kg à laquelle il aurait été
condamné
s'il était coupable ce qu'il comptait
c'est ce que nous ce que nous contestons
ci puisque nous pensons qu'il ne l'est
pas mais en tout cas nous pensons que
deux ans et demi dans cette souffrance
dans cette détention misérable vraiment
ça suffit merci de ce qu'il fait pour
les professions nous allons cependant
délicat une langue commune faisons
depuis deux ans merci